what's going on mosey nation in this
video this is a hot take uh that i had
when i was uh
very very fed up with the amount of
people who are failing at life in
business um and this is one of the top
300 videos that i released into a
private uh community that i had for uh
three or four years
that were not public um and so i wanted
to share the share kind of the best of
that community and uh this one was
entitled i have the tiger and sustained
victory and it was i think a a my chat
mind set and perspective shift that will
provide significant value to you and i
think it will be worth the uh the
investment of time to get the the return
from it and so uh if you're new to the
channel by the way my name is oxford
music i own acquisition.com
it's a portfolio of companies that is
about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you all right so i make
this channel and i make these videos
because a lot of people were broke and i
don't want to be one of them and so that
is why i try and share the lessons and
the failures that we've had to get to
this point because i think that a lot of
people can be more successful if they
just had a couple of different tools and
frameworks to see the world so lots of
love and enjoy the video
what i wanted to talk to you about today
was i have the tiger so i just had our
like a three-day mastermind type thing
with the top sellers so two of the three
gyms who came here were over seven
figures and the other one is gonna
probably hit it within the next three
months um so it's really it was great
because it was a really higher level
conversation that i might typically have
with a much burst which is fun what we
talked about was kind of more amorphous
but i think it's incredibly valuable and
i think it's probably the the one thing
that sets apart the guys who are really
winners slash gals who are really
winners and the ones who aren't and so
it's really just around hunger what i
mean by that is recently i had some of
our some of our older og gym lords
who've been a while you know i mean they
they they turn their gym around they've
grown they're you know you know close to
seven figures or right around there and
they've been doing it for a while
and they were complaining about show
rates they're like hey our show rates
are low
and um you know you go through the same
well you're doing the reminders are you
doing all this stuff like yeah yeah
we're doing all this stuff okay cool
and i dig a little bit deeper and i look
and it turns out that they're only open
one hour per day
at 7 15 a.m
for their availability availability for
for new clients
and i'm like
how the [ __ ] do you think that you're
going to grow your business if the only
time that you can take new customers is
at 7 15 a.m in what world does that make
sense right like imagine a grocery store
that's only open from seven to 7 30
because that's when it's convenient for
the owner what chance do you think that
that that grocery store has at
succeeding virtually none and so what
happens is
people have success they implement
tactics they use gym watch and then they
make money right and then what happens
they get comfortable they get complacent
right and they lose their hunger like
after that point everything like it's
almost like i was supposed to say like
after you after you've like
made it in your mind and that's what's
funny is that making it in some people's
mind is like having 10 grand at the bank
account so like it's scary in terms of
what level of making it is but like once
people have made it i almost want to say
like none of these tactics matter
because you're just not hungry like it
doesn't matter like the obvious [ __ ] you
aren't doing you know what i mean if
your child
was going to die or your spouse or your
city together your family member
whatever it was was going to die unless
you succeeded unless you got more
clients unless you made more money with
your gym
how would you approach it right would
you only be available for one hour a day
would you only be available from seven
to eight a.m would you only set aside an
hour a day to prospect for new customers
would you only reach out to your
existing customers if they hadn't shown
up for a month sometimes people ask
questions that they already know the
answer to it's like duh no [ __ ] right
and and and it goes back to the the main
thing which is like what drives you but
i think what drives you what drives you
to be better what drives you to continue
to want to win i was asked that question
yesterday by the the gym words that were
here and i think honestly it comes from
a dark place and i think i've said this
before but like i'm saying it again
because i think people need to hear it
sometimes you have to wonder like why is
it that only when someone else's life is
on the line do you then actually try
right like why is it only then you
actually cut all the noise out of your
life and then would go laser focused on
actually succeeding like why can't
we
do that all the time right like why
can't we do that
because it's like well then i wouldn't
be happy whatever right like whatever
happiness means right and so the people
who are the most successful in the world
are driven by something that is deep
inside of them that it's normally an
insecurity or a fear of some sort
if you are only trying to make enough to
live on you will always only make enough
to live on
and you will slack the moment you get
comfortable and you will wonder why is
it that as soon as i start making money
i stop because you actually don't want
to make more
that's why you actually don't want to
make more and so
your internal motivation is not there
like because you've accomplished what
you set out to accomplish the real
question is do you actually want what
you claim to want do you actually want
it because if you did you'd already have
it you'd already you'd already be
willing to sacrifice other things in
order to achieve it and that might mean
like maybe waking up earlier maybe like
working 4 to 8 p.m to take sales
appointments or whatever that thing is
it's just the obvious [ __ ] like if you
were coaching you
what would you recommend you to do right
like a lot of times if you think about
like
you most of the time know
what
to do like you do on some level like you
probably know that you're like man i do
stupid [ __ ] sometimes right you probably
think that on some level sometimes right
then you're like man if i were if you
could step out of yourself and say i
need to coach myself you probably have
the answer and it's just that you don't
do it for some reason and so all of your
attention should be on that reason why
is it that this thing has prevented me
from doing the things that i already
know i should do like this last
mastermind that i had
for the top sellers was really
interesting for me because it was the
first time that i had no one who had
extra [ __ ] i didn't have any like
everyone there had really like
clean lives outside like really focused
and just focused on doing the things
that we're gonna grow their business the
conversations are actually really easy
and very direct
most times it's like okay well here's
the obvious hole in your business but
you're not doing anything about it so
let's attack why you're not doing
anything about it right and so then i
have to spend the next hour and a half
digging into why they're not doing
anything about it which has much more to
do with how they manage their headspace
and how they manage their relationships
and how they manage their you know
because what ends up happening is they
start focusing on their business their
personal life goes to shambles they then
are like oh my gosh my personal life is
going to shambles i need to stop paying
attention my business they go to pay
attention to their personal life and
their gym explodes right it's just this
consistent cycle because they just don't
know how
to just do both or they don't know how
to prioritize those all this to say like
it's just like how hungry are you like
how willing are you to put in what you
need to achieve like and if you're not
then that's cool then just to stop stop
saying you want it you know i mean just
be like i only want to make ten thousand
dollars a month
that's it it's like cool
then just say that and be good with it
rather than constantly complaining about
how you're not because you're not even
willing to do the things that
that you already know you should do like
right now i get on the phone the gym
owners are like i know i should work my
leads harder i know i know i should go
through the sales trainings more like i
know i should you know go through the
portal i know i should i know i should
meet with my team more i know i should
pour my like then why aren't you why
aren't you
like why like why
like i know like i know you have time
because other people have time and have
the same business as you so you have
time so why aren't you because once you
have the tactics right and this is one
of the biggest the freeing and also most
soul-crushing parts of gym launch is
that once once once a gym owner joins
gym launch
you know how to make a seven-figure gym
you know how to do it and so then it
reflects back onto you
it's like oh [ __ ]
i'm the reason that we're not there and
you have to swallow that right because
up until they go to gymlodge people been
doing it for five years seven years
eight years and they're like i don't
know how
and then once they see how then they're
like oh [ __ ] i'm not sure if i'm willing
to do that it's like cool once they know
that there is no secret there is no hack
it's literally like a micro photos he
uses the term chopping wood like i call
doing the boring work it's like it's
chopping wood it's reps it's day in day
out you got to reach out to people you
got to give great service write the
handwritten cards like remind people to
weigh in you have to work the leads when
the person comes in the door you have to
be enthusiastic you gotta greet them
with a smile you have to ask the same
questions over and over and over again
because to that person is the first time
they've ever heard and it doesn't matter
if it's the hundredth time that month
you asked the same questions to that
person to that person's day one and so
if you were trying to be successful do
you think that only having availability
for sales appointments at 7 15
to 7 45 in the morning once a day is
going to get you the optimal outcome
do you need a coach to tell you that
really you know what i mean like really
and and so like or or there was another
one i saw that was like between 9 a.m
and 11 am
that was their availability hmm
good luck with that that's when that's
when the people who have the most money
are available right nine to one during
the week we know what to do
right
anyone who's in our world like you know
what to do it's just you have to figure
out why you're not doing it right and
then attack that because the tactics
aren't the thing anymore right the
tactics are there you can read a book
and give it away for free right like
you can do that but like figure out why
you're not hungry
figure out why you're not like why
you're not trying like just figure it
out like there might be something inside
maybe you don't want more
and like you need to discover that it's
like okay then like now you know
but like if you claim to want more
and yet you can't do what's necessary to
get more
then that's where your attention should
go and you should figure that out
because otherwise this doesn't matter
what tactics there are you're just not
going to do them anyways so what's the
point so anyways it was incredibly
refreshing to have the three guys who
are out here um we had ed turner uh mike
great phones both of those guys have
been over you know some figures uh run
rates for a while and doing really
really well those guys were just like
what do i need to do like because
they're like they're clear eyes you know
toes forward know exactly what to do and
i was like why is it that these meetings
are so much easier than some of the
other
meetings i had and so we've probably
spent
a little bit of the day kind of digging
into that and um it's just a question
how bad you want it i really think
that's it and like figuring out why
you're not doing what you already know
you should do
in order to achieve it like do you need
to go pay someone a bunch of money in
order to then get motivated i don't know
like hopefully your kid doesn't need to
be kidnapped in order for you to get
motivated about your business hopefully
right and so it's like what what is that
thing for me it's just fear it's just
fear and insecurity it's fear failing
fear of not being good enough fear of
people who hated to be right you know
what i mean that's what my fear
and so i just like that's what drives me
it's not about money
like it couldn't have been about money
because i don't need any more for the
rest of my life at all it's like it
can't be about that but if it is like
about that for you and you feel like
when you make your first twenty thousand
dollars take a month your first forty
thousand take a month your first fifty
thousand hundred thousand dollar take a
month the first time you hit that
like if that's where you're like oh and
you feel this big sigh of relief then
your motivation is not coming from the
right place
i'm telling you straight up if you feel
relief
when you make a lot of money one month
your motivation is not coming from the
place of a champion
if you want to be the best in the world
at something
that's not going to do anything for you
you shouldn't feel anything from that
you feel nothing
really because it's not about that
that's just that's just an output that's
an output from internal efforts and
should be focused more on the internal
efforts and all of the deficiencies that
you probably had and still hitting 100k
it's like oh my gosh
if we hadn't done this this and this we
would have been less right and if we had
done this in this we would have been
more like that's what you're focusing on
and you're only focusing on those things
and um if you can do that
then you'll be able to unlock something
inside of you that's much stronger than
what might currently be driving you
anyways guys hope you have an amazing uh
saturday drop a like if you feel like
this is cool drop a comment if you feel
like it was cool if you don't then
that's cool too anyways guys have an
amazing day and i will catch you guys
soon hopefully that was valuable for
somebody who is on the fence who's like
not sure about why they can't achieve
what they want why they can't be
consistent
it's because your motivation is not
coming from the right place right
you're just trying to make enough money
to live on and the moment you make
enough money you stop working and then
you wait for things to blow up again
until you try hard again how many times
all right i'm going to a second little
rant how many times have you needed to
make money and then immediately made the
amount of money that you needed in like
a day in like a week right you need to
make payroll i gotta make 10 grand the
next three days how do how many times
has that happened to you and you always
make it work
why
because you already know what the [ __ ]
to do
right you just choose not to do it
you choose not to do it you choose not
to make money when you know how to make
money because whenever you need to make
money you make it and so that's what you
have to attack you have to figure out
why when you already know how to make
money you don't do it that is the the
summary of this entire this entire talk
that i was trying to get out of myself
is like you already know how to do it
when you need to do it you do do it so
why aren't you doing it that is what you
need to focus on and if you can conquer
that piece
no amount of money in the world will
satisfy you and that is what's going to
unlock your ability to become greater
and for you to build your business to
something that is much greater than
yourself because if the only thing that
you want to satisfy is you you're going
to stay this small you're gonna say this
big because to satisfy a single person
or a single family doesn't mean a lot
right but if you want to satisfy a
community you want to satisfy a state
you're a satisfied nation you want to
satisfy an entire group of people it has
to be bigger than you
and um and so yeah so anyways uh
hopefully that might have resonated with
somebody and if it didn't then um i
apologize for the extra aggressiveness
on this saturday morning um but anyways
drop a like drop comment and uh lots of
love and i'll catch you guys on the flip
side all right